Tim ferriss here,
author of the four hour work week for our body for our shift tools of titans and
so on and so forth.
I talk a lot about stoic philosophy and I've had a lot of questions about stoke
philosophy.
I've produced audio books about stoic philosophy which have made their way into
Superbowl teams all the way from management to players and everything in
between.
Why do I talk about stoic philosophy so much?
Well,
to a lot of people who are watching this as was true for me for a very long
time.
You hear stoic and you think maybe of a cow standing in the rain just accepting
whatever tragedy in terrible circumstances befall it.
That is not what I'm advocating at all.
Or maybe you imagine somebody with no emotion whatsoever.
Also not what I'm advocating.
So the way we use stoic in modern English is somewhat different from the way
that it was used when it came from [inaudible],
which is actually porch and specifically I think that stoicism is a fantastic
operating system for thriving in high stress environments.
What does that mean?
It means that it is a framework for making better decisions in training yourself
to be less reactive.
It goes very well with different types of meditation,
whether that's TM or using an app like headspace or calm and so on,
but you don't necessarily need both.
They're complementary stoke philosophy.
And I should say that probably around 2004,
I picked up a book that was the collected letters of Seneca Seneca,
the younger who's one of the real figureheads,
I would say,
uh,
in the last few years at least,
who has become very popular as a stoic thinker and writer has been popular for
some thousand plus years.
Uh,
but there's been a huge resurgence.
Others would include Marcus Aurelius who used to be the emperor of Rome,
the,
the most powerful man in the world at the time.
And then there are others,
Cato and so on.
Epictetus,
who was formerly a slave.
So you have a very wide spectrum of well known stoic thinkers and you should
find the one that speaks to you best.
But I picked up this book of Seneca's writing,
didn't really expect much of it.
And when people ask me now,
what is your favorite book of all time?
The book you've read the most,
the book you've gifted the most.
I've gifted hundreds of copies of Seneca's letters.
So the moral letters to Luke use,
l,
U,
C I,
l.
I,
U s,
the moral letters to leukemias by Seneca,
the younger,
he was a very famous playwright,
one of the wealthiest people in Rome,
advisor to the emperor that ultimately didn't work out so well for him.
But,
uh,
he was on the front line.
So what I appreciate about stoic philosophy is how well it is used in highly
challenging circumstances and the,
some of the basics of stoic philosophy,
which have been applied in the Superbowl,
which had been applied in training of all different types that had been applied
by prisoners of war qws in wartime,
like Stockdale for instance,
James Stockdale,
uh,
are,
I would say a a few things.
Number one,
it trains you much like the serenity prayer in a way,
but it's more systematic to focus on differentiating between the things that you
can control and things you cannot control and really only focusing your energy
on the former.
So for instance,
if you watch your friends spinning out of control on social media,
freaking out about politics and all they do is bitch and whine and whinge about
politics,
well,
if we sat down and thought about it,
the vast majority of those people are not going to be in a position nor are and
take steps to change any of that reality.
Therefore,
it is a lot of wasted energy and calories and brain cycles,
right?
So really,
really learning to repetitive,
repetitively,
consistently focus on things that are within your sphere of control.
That doesn't mean that you are passive.
And certainly the reason that people like Thomas Jefferson,
George Washington,
the founders of this great country of the United States of America,
we're certainly rebels and revolutionaries and extremely aggressive and
contrarion in many,
many ways went to stoicism is because they knew they had a,
a lot of hard battles ahead and they wanted to make wise decisions.
All right.
So number one,
you're learning to focus on and expand the sphere of action that you have,
the things that you can control.
Next,
you're going to systematically train yourself to be less prone to overreacting,
to say criticism.
So Kato,
who is considered by some to be the perfect stoic,
fascinating characters.
See,
ATO would sometimes wear a tunic of an unpopular color so that he would be
ridiculed in the Senate and by other people he did this specifically and other
things like it,
so that he would train himself to only be ashamed of those things worth being
ashamed of.
So the superficial things he would experiment with and he would catalyze other
people making fun of him or insulting him so that he would develop a tolerance
for it.
Uh,
this is very,
very practical and
there are many corollaries to this,
uh,
as well as the next piece,
which is
in effect practicing poverty in the worst case scenarios that they hold less
power over you.
And that could take the form of say Kevin Kelly who's been on the Tim Ferriss
show podcast,
fascinating technology futurist as well as founding editor of wired magazine.
So he knows worst case scenario because he has done so much backpacking and
lived off of instant oatmeal,
that worst case scenario,
he can always have his backpack,
instant oatmeal and a cup of coffee and he be happy.
And he knows that because he's practiced it.
And Seneca in letter 13 of his letters to Luke Ileus,
the moral letters to Lucilius,
which was I believe on festivals and fasting talks about setting aside a certain
number of days,
and I'm paraphrasing here,
but a certain number of days during which you will eat the cheapest affair where
the coarsest of dress,
et Cetera,
asking yourself all the while,
is this the condition that I so feared?
So practically speaking,
I've built this into my own life by fasting,
by exposing myself to cold,
I have a practice of cold exposure,
which has done very safely.
I have different types of planned suffering and planned poverty so that any type
of unplanned suffering or unplanned financial hit will have less of an impact on
me.
And this applies in many different fields.
This is I suppose,
a compatible ethos with the more you sweat in peace time,
the less you bleed in war time.
All right?
You want to prepare for the unexpected turns of fate by simulating what the
worst case scenarios would be.
This is very,
very practical.
And then if we look back to Keto for instance,
while he would wear these ridiculous outfits,
you know,
I will spend time walking through say California,
uh,
in San Francisco,
okay,
hippie liberal central with say a cowboy hat on just to see what happens because
you will get all sorts of sideways glances and so on.
Uh,
and I might then go to Utah.
I went to a very conservative part of Utah and I wore what I call my party pants
for a day or two and party pants are these a very flamboyant,
bright blue,
a floral pattern pants from bonobos.
I don't know if they sell them anymore,
which affects we look like the upholstery on your grandma's couch.
They're hideous.
And did that very deliberately to force me to interact with people in a way that
would condition me to be able to take bolder steps or have more uncomfortable
conversations in the future because all serious problems,
all important matters,
require uncomfortable conversations.
I think you can measure your success in many ways by the number of uncomfortable
conversations you're willing to have and stoicism helps with that.
So I go down the list,
but there are very,
very practical steps to take and then you can translate that into your own life.
So,
for instance,
a lot of the advice that you might get from a former navy seal commander like
Jocko Willink,
he wouldn't call stoicism.
But the mental toughness that he has developed and also train in other people is
very much not going to say identical,
but a a close cousin to stoicism.
And uh,
if,
if you look at for instance,
advice that you would get once you're thrust into the public eye.
And a lot of these letters,
the moral letters killers are along the lines of,
Dear Luke alias,
I hear you're being slandered by your so called friends.
So and so in the Senate.
And he did this,
but then he said this behind your back,
here's how I would recommend that you deal with the situation.
And I would translate that into,
for instance,
advice that I give people who are about to get a lot of public exposure.
And I say,
you never as bad as they say you are and you're never as good as they say you
are.
All right.
And I want to touch on a common misconception or maybe aspect of stasis and
people find unattractive.
So you're never as bad as they say you are.
You're also never as good as they say you are and this helps you to keep a level
head.
Some people fear that if they,
if they adopt stoicism or study so awesome that they will become this very
Volkan like creature that has neither,
that certainly has,
uh,
has less of a dip in terms of the lows of life,
but that simultaneously you're going to sacrifice the highest.
You won't have the peaks of joy that you experience as a normal person if you
focus on stoicism to that.
I would say number one,
you are thinking person and much like any book you would read,
you can pick and choose.
So you can pick and choose the elements that you find most useful that you think
are going to be most applicable to you and then you can test them.
All right.
So I happen to think of my own philosophies not as stoicism and not as a,
as an evangelist necessarily for stoicism to proselytize other people.
I pull from elements of say Buddhism or Zen Buddhism.
I also pull elements from epicureanism which was really seen as almost the
opposite of Stoicism,
but uh,
to be maximally content and to find joy in the small things.
I find that to be very helpful.
A counterbalance to some of the stoicism which can get a little dry and somber
at times.
Uh,
but what stoicism will do if you embrace it in many respects and a zen Buddhism
also very helpful for this is help you to develop a present state awareness so
that you are aware of your thoughts and emotions if before they take control of
you and lead you to make very bad decisions,
whether that's lashing out at someone verbally,
whether that is making an impulse buy or sell decision or otherwise.
It is a fantastic insurance policy that allows you to have more consistent
wellbeing throughout your life in all areas.
And that to me rather than a cow standing in the rain is stoicism.
And certainly I view it as one of the,
the keys to any success that I have had in the last decade or more,
whether that is in the world publishing,
podcasting,
angel investing or otherwise.
I really think that this is a core underlying foundation upon which my best
decisions have been built.
So I hope the same for you.
And ps,
I feel so strongly about the value of this,
and I want to thank everyone who's listened to my podcast or read anything that
I've written that I've put together three volumes of stoic writing,
primarily Seneca,
and I'm giving them away for free.
So I'm giving them way as ebooks.
It's called the Tao of Seneca Tao,
the Tao of Seneca.
And there are gorgeous original illustrations that I had commissioned.
There is incredible calligraphy from both Japanese and Chinese masters because I
wanted to show some of the parallels between philosophical schools that are
dropped into this.
And it features a,
I want to say at least 120 letters from Seneca to Lucilius.
So you can find those for free.
And I really hope that.